Don't stop
Don't stop walking.
Keep on walking.
Oh, my god. Jahar, my friend.
Yes, Karim.
We are a long way from home.
Oh. Every American woman
is more infidel
than the last, my friend.
You're telling me.
You're telling me
my good friend.
Yes. Oh, there's a nine o'clock,
nine o'clock, nine o'clock.
Here she comes. Blip.
Okay. Come on.
Full frontal face.
Only in America, baby.
Only in America.
Grab it. Grab it.
What did you see?
I want to grab.
Want that? Take it.
I'm going to take it.
This is yours.
And then that is yours.
This one here? What did you see?
What did you see?
I'll tell you what I saw.
What?
I got to see the forearms.
A little bit of the thighs.
Yes. Oh, I saw this.
And I definitely got
some ankle knot.
You got ankle knot?
Oh, I got ankle knot.
Oh, the whole baba ghanoush?
You're telling me. It's like
we've got the x-ray visions.
You're Superman.
You're Superman, ah?
Oh, here we go.
Here we go. Here we go.
Holy tabouli. Would you look
at the leg elbows on that one?
Mm-hmm.
I'll tell you what.
What I wouldn't do
for a six seconds with her.
Yes, you would. Yes, you would.
What would you do?
I want to show you right now.
You're going to show me?
Spot me!
You've got to spot me because
Yes, I am her. I am her.
Yes. I'll tell you
what I would do right now.
I would pump her full of iron.
And then I would lift her
to the ceiling.
I'm her.
Lift her to the ceiling.
Working the body.
Doing the head.
head.
Belly button.
We've got belly button.
Oh, my god.
Oh, my god a belly button.
That's belly button, my friend.
I couldn't believe we saw
the belly button.
I've never seen the belly button
on a woman before.
I thought it was a myth.
Yes. It's like the butt hole
of the belly.
Kiss. Kiss.
Oh, what I wouldn't do for her.
What would you do?
Give me the ... Oh.
Show me.
Give me the ball.
Show me. Show me.
I'm going to show you right now.
Come on.
I'm ready.
I get in here.
Come on. It feel good. Yes.
Grab the hair.
Into it. Yes.
Hold the hair. Okay.
Come on switch positions.
Switch positions.
Lock arms.
I will show you the world.
Come on.
Shining, shimmering splendid.
Don't do that. Close your eyes.
Yes, princess. Yes.
Infidels.
Homosexual and American devils.
Give them the whistle
of disapproval.
I will right now.
That is my boy.
That should teach.
That is my boy, huh?